marriage satisfaction and joy is higher
with couples that see themselves as one
when it comes to money for so many
people they're running these kind of
these two separate Lanes trying to
figure out okay who pays what Bill
what's fair what's equal when you just
scrap all of that and say hey this is
our house when our incomes come in it is
our income what are we going to do with
our money and you see yourself as a team
as one as unified and my thing is I'm
like if you can share a bed you can
share a bank account you guys are
married you are one you are together now
in your budget you have a line item you
have money to go and spend and enjoy and
that's great you know I have a Rachel
line item
and I can go buy us sweaters and new
pair of jeans and I'm not having to like
text him every time right we have a
certain amount of money that I get to
spend every month a certain amount of
money he spends but that's agreed upon
something changes not just tactically
things change when you combine accounts
but emotionally the unity that's created
you start to see yourselves as one